hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now before we
get back into it I just wanted to
comment that that girl's face is getting
more and more distorted and actually is
getting more and more separated and
there's a red light behind it kind of a
reveal of the machine within and
whatever also I turned on subtitles so
there's that apologize I usually do that
every time I start up a game but I
forgot this time because no oh that's
handy it told me exactly what I was
supposed to be doing okay okay so now
we're back and we left bubble Bubba hind
but hopefully bubble butt will return
once more in the future
oh hey where did I get a purse is it
shooting out of my eyeballs cuz I'm a
robot I'm pretty sure I'm a robot
so probably both of my eyeballs or
flashlights well I guess I don't need to
worry about anything actually killing me
because I don't even know I'm a robo
hello
boink apparently I missed a few Robo
vaginas Jesus Christ what the hell yeah
what the hell I don't know why would you
do it in the first place I don't even
know what it's supposed to do okay
insufficient power I'm gonna need to
light up the power somewhere this oh
hell Minh
okay let's go down the dark and scary
hallway hello
don't mind me it's your friendly
neighborhood robot robot amongst friends
shouldn't be too much of a problem
anyway okay good I was wondering when I
was gonna see more of that yeah yeah
okay so I imagine is at some point gonna
collapse on top of me because that's
usually what happens in these
underground situations
hi are you doing lovely day weather huh
uh okay
hey are you me hey hon can I help you
don't let me die nothing is allowed to
die
well what about Paul or floral or
whatever his name was back there an
accident fixing the power I was going to
say des anything I can be if you see
masters are harmed tell them I need okay
Amy needs help I was thinking that you
were Amy I just didn't want to make any
assumptions and actually I'm gonna walk
up and talk to everything apparently
wait so would it be would it be bad to
done blog this would you die I mean it
seems to be breathing forward review
with this weird lung thing kind of
reminds me of dead space though the
creatures that were breathing that were
like mutated to breathe noxious fumes
into the air
are you okay I don't think I'm doing a
good thing when I don't know any
alternative power supply unstable safety
systems offline
okay that's good right that's good
enough I guess I won't be safe but at
least she'll still be alive
do I even want her to be alive oh is
that any way to live I have no idea I
don't even know how I'd get her out if I
could my instinct tells me that if I
unplug the other one she's definitely
gonna die but I don't know she's like
the only other actually human thing that
I've seen I got a bad feeling about this
oh and only so close to retirement uh
this game is throwing a lot of really
interesting conundrum brooms at me okay
I mean if I'm a robot she would have
seen it right she would have would have
been very obvious Yes No maybe so okay
can't get that open no ah here we go
this is what people were talking about
I'm trying to be more explorative and
actually see everything um is that a
recipe for a but is that a recipe for
bubble butt Oh bubble butt I see you
there hello handsome how you doing our I
don't know my Greek letters I never
joined up okay manifest shuttle beat uh
on this morning at January 12th the
comic Telos crashed into the Pacific
open the impact ranks is one of the
largest collisions ever recorded on
earth all evidence indicates that the
surface has been completely barren and
it's no longer able to sustain life whoo
unique location provided unparalleled
safety for our staff some structural
damage has been noted but no casualties
reported the large Slough was weather
and communication station located on the
surface platform Omega okay so I was
right no hello hi
kids were not [ __ ] my parents in the
ice they're gonna bomb shelter upstate
by the way along with your dad I'm
guessing someone while I'm send you a
message so Meno I mean I hope they will
now I'm not even sure you'll get this
message if you do I want you to know
I've never blamed you for following your
dreams
it just
oh it's just mad it didn't fit better
with what I imagine our lives would be
where you want a little picket fence big
family you know I guess what I'm trying
to say is I'm poor out of you and even
though it's been difficult to be
separated from you
I heard read nothing I'm happy and I
really wish I was able to say this
without sky falling down I love you Amy
oh well well Amy's back there so I guess
I should try to keep her alive yes I
mean I don't know what I can do I really
don't know what I could possibly change
or influence to make it actually go the
way it is why did it come and fall in
calling all these robos to be bad
Oh No emergency only isn't this a little
bit of a burr okay that didn't sound
good well alrighty then what did I do
how did I screw up this time we're in in
what way am i terrible Oh Oh Rob's okay
so Amy's still back there and Amy's
still alive to some extent whatever you
could call being alive in that state
floodable airlock adaptable pipes great
I didn't need all that other stuff I'll
just make do with my Robo body that can
breathe underwater and have flashlights
shooting out of a nose I guess I'll be
back all right okay here we go
wait hopefully I did the right thing cuz
I know how you guys would roast me alive
if I didn't do the right thing
unreliable power I know I know I have no
choice I must take this risk I think oh
I get it
let's go with caution ooh I like my Robo
legs okay so leave a doobie flute clip
I'm just guessing here push the big red
button oh oh okay I'm at Epsilon I need
to go to lambda or did I need to go to
theta well I need to go to lambda first
anyway so
confirm destination lambda okay is he
more like that space little tram system
going everywhere although you didn't
have any control over that one oh it's
so cool I love how deep the world is
like how much environment and uh like
I've always said Oh eta two minutes
God what am i doing welcome to pathos to
your expressway to the Stars we're under
the ocean the remaining operational
sixties has now become home to the Omega
space Sun the world's most affordable
way to launch satellites and deep space
probes our unique Atlantic Ocean
location allows for this gigantic coil
gun running longer than a marathon to
safely launch projectiles without risk
of damaging the payload with risky
optical sights and has a diverse staff
of engineers and scientists
and take us to is also the home from
multiple research projects within the
marine sciences including hydro culture
turbulence and deep sea construction we
are now leaving the salon for
shipping dock and transportation out
there you will be able to find shuttle
trains leading to all the other parts of
the station working walkie-talkie man I
still don't know if I did the right
thing but what I'm saying it's like I
love how rich the world is like there's
so much to be said from just walking
around in the environment and I'm gonna
try my boys is worth here I shouldn't
have done that or maybe it was gonna
happen anyway I mean it's not like
turned it off the other power would have
done okay I really do wonder if this
game has a lot of different endings if
there's a lot of different choices to be
made and what's great about is it the
choices aren't obviously apparent just
like in the beginning I could have sent
that email or I couldn't not and I
wouldn't even known the difference or I
could have talked to that robot or maybe
I shouldn't what's going on hello oh
here we go Oh hooray
good for me my robe um um eyes are
starting to be faulty oh boy I mean
obviously the game looks good I mean I
don't know how next generation you can
quite call it considering that this is
made on a new evolution of the previous
engine that amnesia the Dark Descent was
made on someone calling me hey hear
something hey right here Catherine is
that you I was on my way but then the
shuttle train it [ __ ] crashed no I'm
not all right what the hell happened in
the world why are we under water oh you
really don't worry about that right now
every lies you confuse
but you're so close to where if you just
keep going I have a feeling you're a
robot too they walk there check the
overall structure from collapsing what
you need to find is your sexual weakness
hatch it'll lead outside name it such no
problem
what's going on out where here there I
heard a wolf like it nothing you okay
hey it's off buddy time to focus on your
own survival and hopefully Amy's okay
and I don't like any of this but
apparently I won't be able to go back so
maybe I made the right choice maybe I
didn't I have no idea okay
look at that I wonder if I should go
down there first though there's the
thing I never know which way to go first
like is this the secret I was supposed
to find her is that the glowing thing
down there that I was supposed to find
that looks like a bot hole I need to
touch
oh no that's not about hole that is a
moving head I'm going in here I'll take
my chances in the mouldy disgusting
corridor that leads to a super awesome
ladder or maybe I was supposed to go
down there are people gonna be mad at me
because it didn't go down to there you
know what even if I die I might as well
go just to see if I can cuz you never
know with these things how merry are you
I'm gonna come come coming to get ya I'm
gonna get ya oh it was a robo vagina
butthole okay
oh he's went whole hog in there didn't
you no hesitation on your part anymore
oh that's not good oh I'm gonna run away
no I thought it might explode on me but
at least I got that I don't know what
that does but at least I have it so now
I'm not a coward I went down there full
force I did everything I was supposed to
do and now I'm climbing out of a well
okay
whooping hope it Boop see that's what
I'm talking about I never know which
oh boy I can't wait to say bubble butt
again bubble butts my favorite mother
once my little bubble buddy
he's the bubbliest buddy you've never
bubbled on your butt okay never mind
then
guess I'm not going anywhere Oh nope a
delude oh thank you
I really hope I see bubble butt again I
mean I have a funny feeling that they
might have a little companion for me out
here oh I know Bubble Boy but I want
bubble butt oh hold on dude without
Bubble Boy I mean really how big in this
ocean be really you gonna say the
stupidest possible thing you can you're
a robot
think properly and find bubble butt
who's bubble butts my buddy
for eternity and beyond he's my little
bubble butt biscuit oh good I don't know
what a bubble butt biscuit is but I'm
not sure I want to know it's so cool are
those Robo fish I don't know I mean
obviously I don't know if I'm saying
that I'm actually a robot I don't know
about that it's entirely possible that
one of my theories that I was coming up
with that I didn't want to say out loud
just in case I was very wrong and I I
didn't want to it but I might as well
talk about is when the scan was done
back in Toronto that made like a copy of
his mind and for whatever reason he
wasn't transported to here it's just
that the copy was pulled from memory at
that juncture therefore the last memory
that he would have would be stepping in
the machine as far as this this entity
goes whoever this is or Simon if it is
Simon there it's very unlikely that
going into that transported him into the
future you know if that just seems
illogical it would be fantastic if that
could happen but I highly doubt that's
actually what's going on here and I
highly imagine that considering all the
other robot malfunctions going on what
it did was made a copy of this entire
mind in the scan and then it was pulled
into the data here for some reason
because that was a pioneer of some
research that happened it was the
originating of something or other and
therefore here he is now and that's what
I was talking about in the last episode
how would you know how would you know
anything was different how would you
know you're not who you say you are
if everything you think and everything
you know is exactly what you think it is
like it's a quandary it's a conundrum
there's lamda okay but that's what's
really interesting about this game and
that's why I'm very excited about it's
because nothing nothing may go oh hey
you're not bubble butt hmm I don't want
to oh god no no no no I'm not hiding
what are you doing
I'm just running away very quickly
that's not hiding yeah always bubble
butt was here and see the same thing
probably happened to those machines they
just started pulling in consciousnesses
this is from the databanks how would
anyone know and especially if the minds
in a machine whose programming is you
know it's just its function is to do one
thing or another
how would it even know that it's doing
anything wrong it's doing something in
accordance with its you know it's its
body it's doing something in accordance
with its new place in life okay so
lambdas over there but I'm gonna check
out over here I really am trying to see
everything but obviously if I miss
something I'm an idiot
just gonna put that right out hello is
it someone's home Patrick is that you do
you live in a high-level owner is he no
you live under a rock what are you doing
here hello what's this all about fancy
electronics work underwater oh no I need
a cortex chip okay so obviously I need
to get that chip it's talking about
because it mentioned that in the
beginning when I first got this
omni-tool wait what about lambda that
bubble but is that bubble but oh that's
Bubble Boy bubble but wait that's not
bubble but that's not but is that bubble
bath bubble but wait no that's a
different bubble but hey you're all
bubble blood to me hey
you you want to be my friend ooh hey see
you hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay all right let's make some
ground rules here you're not a bubble
but you're never gonna be bubble but you
won't replace bubble butt and frankly
weirding me out with your weird pig nose
whatever oh well I got you know so I
imagine that the other complexes are
gonna be very very very very very very
very far away so I don't wanna walk that
distance does that red light bad on a
lesson I don't know what you're doing
why are you making my vision go to Lulu
stop coming towards me okay bye
right so I'm assuming I needed this
little guy to follow me for no really
okay whatever I'm just gonna try to go
in lambda I imagine there's not much to
explore out here anyway
but I did find an escape vessel so
that's nice
you mean Kathryn bond but justice robot
okay time to get noisy
refreshing
I feel minty fresh hello okay so alright
then seems to be pretty similar to the
other places in that it's abandoned
decrepit in the
okay then
alright then there's a family feud going
on down there nothing like Kathryn
nothing I should get in the way up don't
look at what don't look at what I want
to look at it i real oh I don't want to
look at it oh I don't want to look at it
boy I don't look at it oh oh oh what do
I do you put on you oh oh what do I do
Oh what do I do oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh I can how am I supposed to
know we're supposed to go towards not
look at it way back up towards it is it
gonna kill me it's gonna stab me in the
back it's gonna stab me in the butt oh
I'm dead
I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm dead a
million ways oh I'm so dead
I can't hide in these I can't hide at
all [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's right up my boy it's not
safe to come out now
you're a liar where did it go I don't
even know what it was it's like one of
the many eyed creatures from blood-borne
are you hurt are you a robot hello hello
are there bad robos and good robos oh
you are a robot you are a robot you are
a robot you are a robo down here
oh not you too was really hoping you
were human girl let the circuitry fool
you I was human once can't take anymore
this is everything's [ __ ]
I give up there's nothing left calm down
it's not the end of the world
you sure it sure as hell looks like it
for all I know there's no one left
except for me what do you mean I'm right
here
don't take this the wrong way but I
meant any humans left except for me have
you looked at yourself lately you're a
walking talking diving suit with some
electronics left on for good measure I
don't you don't want to think about it
we'll start thinking about it I don't
want to do this anymore
I don't want to be this I want out
before you do anything hasty could you
help me with something what I was trying
to find out what happened was my project
when that brute knocked me to the ground
the project how could anything possibly
matter when you knew your stupid robot
in a stupid dead world okay focus I need
you to fix me so I can get back to work
then you can sulk as much as you want
you've gotta be kidding right I think I
have a better chance of building myself
a time machine than of putting you back
together I just need to access the
computer Oh
set it on the tool you're hearing oh the
door opener I picked it up at Upsilon
where woke up I don't have to do plug it
into the terminal sure whatever
yep I had a pretty good feeling about
all this I mean you're loaded just plug
my cortex chip into the tool what's a
cortex - it will be obvious I'll eject
it for you
just grab the chip and slide it into the
omelet tool come on I just need you to
do this one thing for me what am i
jamming into where and what am i sliding
over what and what am i doing what did
you want me to do the tool you're
carrying plug it into the computer over
there over there all over here okay
obviously the omni-tool place boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo boo I'm a robo I'm
gonna close this door
should be easy enough just pick up the
chip and slide it into the Omniture hang
up your tabletop chip to the door oh
it's standardized connect hug Catherine
all right let's give this a try okay
already then thanks for the chip I guess
boobity boo be boo boo do papa robo Oh
your robos got Robo goop on it Papa Jane
wasn't very helpful anyway just pretty
much anything with it oh this feels
weird I'm in the AMA - thanks so what's
the project about why about it oh well I
saved all the people on the station as
brain scans and put them into an
artificial world we were gonna launch it
into space to save from uh well all of
this are you telling me that you were
going to launch a computer world filled
with people into space yes it was just a
pet project at first but it got a really
serious after the comment took out the
surface then suddenly it became very
important and it was officially named
the arc that's appropriate how far did
you get wanna know that version of me
that I am he came from scan I did pretty
early on the living Catherine could very
well finish the project and launched it
I guess she could even still be alive
huh weird thought so the talking robots
are they also scans you did they could
be but I doubt it I'd expect much more
sense if that was the case all right
fire what's happening I managed to
restore some data from the backup server
this should tell us everything we need
Oh could you do me a favor and run into
the other room and have a look I don't
seem to be able to view the files in
this condition I need to know that the
Ark is safe
sure keV Thanks I'll unlock the door for
you Thanks okay this isn't weird at all
putting Peter
oh never mind I thought I was gonna take
you with me but I mean this is what I
was talking about this is exactly what I
was talking about the brain scans like
well as I said before you from Toronto
yeah I just went in for a brain scan and
suddenly Here I am that doesn't make any
sense help why would anyone bring a scan
from Toronto you think that's strange
what if I tell you it was back in 2015
Oh yep there we go like it's exactly
what I was saying in the whole concept
of if you copy and tie a person's entire
consciousness are they alive if they can
think and make judgments for themselves
are they human like where do you draw
the line what what is the line like I'm
pretty sure that's the question this
whole game is about and it's awesome
it's awesome it's really cool you say
something sorry still trying to figure
out how you got here yeah that it I'd
really like to know who thought sending
Canadian to the bottom of the sea was a
good idea
uh-huh yeah interesting on all sorts of
mind games going on here I'm just trying
to find everything I've stayed up all
night seems like a waste of sleep I got
the TV on the background the newscasters
are covering the important incoming
comment like they were counting down for
New Year's Eve I know it's messed up
wishing you were here with me I suppose
if anyone has a chance to survive this
thing it would be you guys below the
waves I hope you were able to go on it's
if it's a life worth living well collect
the shit's about to hit the fan I better
set hit Send before the shock wave
reaches us I'm proud of you Boyd that
Wow
that is there's really no way I can
comment killed the planet Wyatt you're
all stranded down here we were the lucky
ones that is so weird it's so weird it's
so weird
that's so weird hearts all soon
maybe dating keep your all's pure
y-you told me not to look at it what
would I keep my eyes peeled that's kind
of the opportunity intended a vague that
I wanted course I mean go hey he's
outside
hi why are you doing that here you same
not bubble but that was ramming into the
building before probably our arty you
dick hey halt this is my underground lab
and you're damaging it are you okay
alright whatever are you here are you in
here I don't like you I'm in a crouch
now for stealth purposes bringing the
one that pretty is stalled the Robo
fluids cuz I have a bone to pick with
you I definitely don't want to pick with
your bone so let's just ignore the fact
that I said anything about Robo fluids
that creature was strangely overbearing
yeah basically it electromagnetism
that's bad for us right confusing at
least your sucess is a good punch
interesting I mean it seems like my
character has kind of accepted the fact
that he's a robot already which is
bizarre considering well I mean I guess
it's not too bizarre I mean people are
able to make sense of things I mean what
is there to accept it's just like that
is the way it is what else is up what
else are we gonna do about it
now what am i trying to do I'm trying to
look for an arc but where is the arc
where is this quote-unquote arc I have
no idea
what am I looking for is it over here is
this please do one of these just tow
computer yes look for anything about
yuck hello
it says hour is that what I'm looking
for I'm just gonna scratch my Robo nuts
and hope for the best
oh hey opinion poll are you excited
about Hey at first I couldn't really see
the point of it but then I thought why
shouldn't wait right I mean if we were
able to save even just a small piece of
ourselves why wouldn't we do that so you
are in favor that I think it's really
important we do this uh-huh who's the
city this guy won't like it it's a great
idea and we have something to do am i
right are you optimistic about the
project chances of the arc reaching
space I can definitely be done you
already solved the biggest problem how
to actually get us all in there now we
have to do is build the damn thing and
hold fire is still operational yeah I
think we can do it there's nothing to be
easy
thanks sailor eating Ian thanks for your
salty opinion now this guy's gonna
disagree on the art project the idea is
just increment by every definition it
really makes you think about what it
means to be here what makes you say man
beyond the basics they aren't the
superficial I'm convinced there's
something with even greater value you've
provided a platform which is not
necessarily restricted to our digital
continent but our needs of jewell
survival
my sincerest belief then we can't go on
living reality well there you have it
then it's oh man it's just so many good
there are so many thought questions so
many deep thinking puzzles to be had in
this game it's so cool but either way
I'm all out of time for this episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
remember these are gonna be daily
uploads and hopefully I won't overlook
anything that's important for you guys
to see thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye that's how you're gonna play
this game a game baby on home come out
and scare me oh boy yeah nothing